[Music]
linear programming is a technique which
helps us to find the optimum solution
for a given problem an optimum solution
is that solution which is the best
possible outcome of a given problem
before we discuss how a linear
programming technique is used to solve
problems let's understand what kind of
problems can be solved using this
technique did you know that this
technique is widely used in different
industries this list includes different
types of linear programming problems
let's now focus on the structure and the
formulation of a linear programming
problem we first need to understand the
given problem and then identify the
basic elements to convert it into a
linear programming problem this process
is called as the formulation of a linear
programming problem understand it well
we first need to convert a given problem
into a linear programming problem and
then solve it so there are two aspects
here the formulation part and then the
solution part let's begin with the
formulation of linear programming
problems go through this example we have
to find the maximum profit the company
can earn with the constraint the
constraint here is the production budget
but how do we approach this problem now
first let's try to represent this
problem in a tabular form can you give
it a try
sure it is go through it well note that
we have to convert this problem into a
linear programming problem and how do we
do that
by writing the given problem in the form
of mathematical expressions like in this
case the company wants to sell some
number of products a and B as they don't
know the exact quantity let's assume the
number of units of product a to be x and
the number of units of product B to be y
now can you tell me the total cost to
manufacture these many units of a and B
respectively yes it will be 200 times X
and 150 times y we're just multiplying
the quantity with the price next let's
look at the constraint it says the
production budget is $50,000 that means
the cost to be incurred should not
exceed $50,000 it can be less than or
equal to $50,000 can you write this
constraint in the form of a mathematical
expression here's the answer this
expression represents the budget
constraint of the problem the total cost
should not be more than $50,000
now let's express the total demand of
the two products in a similar manner
give it a try the combined monthly
demand of the two products will not
exceed 500 units therefore we use the
less than or equal to sign to write this
expression and which constraint does
this expression represent yes it
represents the demand constraint of the
given problem this means if the company
produces more than 500 units of products
a and B in all it might not be able to
sell them are there any other
constraints in the problem
not really so let's look at the profit
element of the two products can you tell
me the objective of the company in this
case the company would like to sell its
products a and B in such a mix that it
yields maximum profit in a month in
simple words the company would try to
maximize the profit which it can yield
by selling a and B now let Z denote the
total profit for the month can you write
the total profit in the form of
mathematical expression the total profit
said can be written as this
it's the product of the quantity and the
profit per unit with this we will write
the objective function of this problem
the objective function in a linear
programming problem is a mathematical
expression of the ultimate goal so we
have the two constraints here a budget
constraint and a demand constraint this
is how the whole problem looks in terms
of mathematical expressions this is the
objective function and these are the two
constraints there's just one thing we
need to know here and for that I want
you to answer a question can the number
of units produced by a company be
negative you're right it can never be
negative so we need to add the
non-negative constraints it can be
written mathematically like this it's
very important to write the non-negative
constraints in the formulation of a
linear programming problem did you
notice what we did the entire problem of
so many words is reduced to the simple
format using mathematical language as
the problem is formulated in the linear
form it's called as linear programming
[Music]